[Música]
[Aplausos]
cuando yo tenía 7 años no soñaba con ser
una doctora o una arquitecta ni una
supermodelo cuando tenía 7 años soñaba
con convertirme en la gerente con más
tenacidad que el mundo hubiera conocido
jamás cuando yo tenía 7 años no me
importaba cuánto tiempo faltaba para el
recreo pero si me importaba cuánto
tiempo faltaba para llegar a mi casa y
poder seguir jugando en mi empresa y es
que mi juego favorito no eran las
barbies no eran los carros pero si era
el dinero y los chocolates cuando tenía
7 años no quería ser la mejor estudiante
de mi salón de clase pero sí que quería
convertirme en una líder mundial que
impactara la vida de miles de personas y
que logrará transformar el sistema
educativo tradicional qué les parece si
devolvemos el tiempo 17 años
es nuestra historia esta es la historia
de tres hermanas colombianas que a los 6
7 y 8 años iniciamos nuestra primera
empresa de chocolates con 10 dólares
vendiendo puerta a puerta después de ir
al colegio esta es la historia de tres
hermanas que convirtieron esta empresa
este juego en una verdadera experiencia
pedagógica a mis siete años yo era la
gerente comercial
karen a sus 8 años era la gerente
general y steffi por supuesto a sus seis
años era la ejecutiva de venta
teníamos cargos manuales de funciones
cuota de venta responsabilidades y demás
y fue así como sin darnos cuenta nuestra
amada empresa se convirtió en la mejor
escuela que transformaría nuestras vidas
para siempre como pueden darse cuenta en
esta historia somos tres hermanas y
evidentemente aquí solamente habemos dos
hace falta nuestra dorada
pero no se preocupen por imaginarse la
mucho pues se las voy a mostrar con
ustedes este a sus seis años vendiendo
masivamente en un congreso internacional
ante cientos de personas
antes de presenciar
[Música]
y
ah
[Música]
y fue precisamente durante este episodio
en donde vendimos nuestros primeros 10
dólares internacionalmente y fueron
precisamente estos 10 dólares los que
nos enseñaron una lección de por vida y
que de hecho inspiran la charla de hoy
además de seguir creciendo nuestra
empresa de chocolates nos dedicamos a
dictar conferencias de emprendimiento
auditorios que reunían miles de personas
iniciamos en colombia después en
latinoamérica y más adelante en el mundo
habiendo llegado hoy a más de 500 mil
personas en 22 países unos años después
publicamos nuestro primer libro cuando
teníamos 13 14 y 15 años y fue
precisamente en ese momento cuando nos
convertimos en la voz de miles de niños
y jóvenes que gritan en silencio por una
educación diferente ahora adelantemos un
poco el tiempo y lleguemos al día de hoy
al presente y al como una empresa un
juego de chocolates
en una plataforma de educación en línea
que lleva habilidades productivas a
miles de estudiantes basados en una
metodología que aplica neurociencias la
pregunta entonces es que hizo que todo
esto fuera posible y más interesante aún
que tiene que ver nuestra historia con
cómo generar dinero en un mundo sin
trabajos pero por qué sin trabajos qué
va a pasar con ellos pues bien la era en
la que vivimos la tecnología está
reconfigurando la forma en la que
vivimos y especialmente está
transformando los mercados laborales
mundiales de forma rápida y contundente
en tres dimensiones la cantidad la
calidad y la distribución de los puestos
de trabajo los rápidos avances
tecnológicos como el vic deira como la
inteligencia artificial como la realidad
virtual están cambiando la forma en la
que trabajamos y si bien es cierto que
ha hecho que ciertos trabajos se vuelvan
mucho más fáciles de real
no podemos negar que ha hecho que la
necesidad de un ser humano en ciertas
posiciones ya no sea tan necesaria y el
reemplazo del esfuerzo humano por la
tecnología disminuyendo drásticamente
los costos ha colocado una gran cantidad
de posiciones en jaque mate según un
reporte del foro económico mundial
llamado el futuro de los trabajos 75
millones de trabajos desaparecerán
carros que se manejan solos farmacias
100% automatizadas robots que hoy día
son bartenders sets agricultores
periodistas analistas financieros y
hasta abogados o como bien lo expresó un
general de las fuerzas militares de los
eeuu un ejército con proyección de
reemplazar un cuarto de sus soldados de
combates por robots antes del 2030 y
este es el momento de recordar que todas
las monedas tienen dos caras y es
precisamente esa
otra cara de la cuarta revolución
industrial la que necesitamos que el
mundo entero entienda especialmente los
más jóvenes el mismo reporte del foro
económico mundial también mostró que 133
millones de nuevos trabajos van a
crearse antes del 2022 y ahí señoras y
señores está el primer gran secreto de
hoy la tecnología no disminuye ni reduce
los trabajos sino que los transforma y
si bien hay ciertas posiciones y ciertos
empleos que no volveremos a ver es
importante entender que hay un sinfín de
nuevas oportunidades que van a crearse
de forma paralela y esos millones de
trabajos que se generarán se centrarán
en tareas que tienen como base
fundamental la creatividad y la
interacción humana mientras que las
máquinas se ocuparán cada vez más de
tareas físicas repetitivas y de
procesado masivo de información es
importante entender también que la
tecnología se consolida como una
para las empresas ya que las ayuda a
escalar a crecer a abrir nuevos mercados
a mejorar sus procesos entendamos que la
tecnología crea nuevas profesiones y con
ellas nuevos empleos y oportunidades de
generar ingresos la pregunta ahora sería
estamos preparados para aprovechar las
oportunidades que trae consigo la cuarta
revolución industrial está el sistema
educativo realmente preparando a los
jóvenes con las habilidades que
necesitan para ser exitosos en el siglo
21 están los padres formando a sus hijos
para ser insustituibles y exitosos y la
gran incógnita cómo generar dinero en un
mundo sin trabajos pues bien en el mundo
que conocemos hoy los trabajos están
transformándose y sólo aquellas
habilidades que realmente agreguen valor
podrán diferenciarnos de los robots
atención porque viene el segundo gran
secreto de hoy
esas habilidades que necesitamos
enfocarnos en desarrollar y fortalecer
para ser realmente exitosos en el siglo
21 son las 46 comunicación colaboración
pensamiento crítico y creatividad
estamos urgidos porque todos los niños y
jóvenes que hoy en día están educando se
desarrollen esas 46 y la manera de
hacerlo es una forma aplicable dinámica
apasionante pero sobre todo de una forma
efectiva y la mejor manera de hacer esto
es a través del emprendimiento estamos
absolutamente convencidas de esto y no
es porque lo hemos leído en un libro ni
es porque lo escuchamos en un podcast es
porque es de muy chiquitas lo hemos
vivido y a través del emprendimiento y
de nuestra empresa de chocolate hemos
logrado desarrollar cada una de esas
cuatro habilidades
esto señoras y señores desarrollo en
nosotros la primera c de la comunicación
ya que tocando puerta puerta tuvimos que
aprender a comunicarnos a perder el
miedo a hablar en público aprender a
dirigirnos a diferentes tipos de
personas esto que ven aquí en mi mano
desarrollo en nosotras la segunda se de
la colaboración ya que teníamos que
trabajar en equipo colaborar con
nuestros empleados con nuestros
proveedores con nuestros clientes esto
desarrolló en nosotras la tercera cee de
pensamiento crítico pues teníamos que
analizar procesar información y sobre
todo resolver problemas de la vida real
y esto señoras y señores desarrollo en
nosotras la cuarta ce de creatividad
pues teníamos que buscar formas
innovadoras de promocionar nuestros
productos de abrir nuevos mercados de
crecer nuestra empresa es importante que
entendamos que el emprendimiento no
solamente es una manera estelar
de desarrollar esos 46 del pensamiento
crítico la creatividad la colaboración y
la comunicación pero además es una
manera de sembrar unas semillas de
empresarialidad una mentalidad necesaria
para generar desarrollo económico y
social en las comunidades y aquí viene
el tercer gran secreto crecimos en una
familia educada por un padre empresario
visionario soñador y un poquito loco y
por una madre educadora apasionada por
enseñar crecimos en un hogar en donde
nuestros padres jamás nos dieron el
pescado pero siempre nos enseñaron a
pescar crecimos en un hogar con unos
padres que nos enseñaron desde muy
chiquitas a creer en nosotros mismos a
pensar de forma divergente a crear
soluciones innovadoras a caernos y a
levantar a ser autónomas flexibles y
resiliente y sobre todo unos padres que
nos enseñaron aquellas habilidades
blandas que nos van a diferenciar de los
robots y aquellas habilidades que hoy en
día
nos hacen ser competitivas fue
precisamente la educación de nuestros
padres la que nos llevó a ganarnos la
vida de la forma como lo hacemos hoy es
por eso que no buscamos empleo pero si
lo creamos y es por eso y gracias a esa
mentalidad que sembraron desde temprana
edad en nosotras que hoy estamos
transformando el mundo a través de la
educación virtual con nuestra empresa
imaginemos ahora por un segundo qué
pasaría si el eje central de la
educación contemporánea fueran las 4 c s
albert einstein decía qué locura es
seguir haciendo las mismas cosas y
esperar resultados diferentes entonces
por qué seguimos enseñando más de lo
mismo a los más chicos es nuestra
responsabilidad y nuestra obligación
mostrarles el panorama completo
mostrarles la otra cara de la moneda y
sobre todo prepararlos para afrontar y
aprovechar una realidad que es inminente
y que no se esconde señoras y señores
estos son 10 dólares igual
los primeros que vendimos
internacionalmente en este vídeo que les
mostré y son exactamente estos 10
dólares y un chocolate los que queremos
utilizar hoy para retarlos a cada uno de
ustedes a transformar el mundo a través
de los 46 alvin toffler decía que los
analfabetas del siglo 21 no serán
aquellas personas que no sepan leer ni
escribir serán aquellas personas que no
sepan aprender desaprender y re aprender
las 46 como habilidades fundamentales
para la vida y el emprendimiento como la
mejor metodología para desarrollarlas
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]